for the first time the LA Lakers LeBron
James is addressing the standoff between
the NBA and China last night the
basketball superstar said the Houston
Rockets general manager Daryl Morey was
quote misinformed or not really educated
when he sent a tweet that supported Hong
Kong's pro-democracy movement Jonathan
Vigliotti is at the Staples Center in
Los Angeles Jonathan and LeBron has
taken a lot of heat for those comments
yes he isn't good morning to you Anthony
the Lakers won their priest he's in-game
here last night but it's what LeBron
James said before the game even began
that's stealing all the attention away
from that win the bronze James
considered one of the most influential
stars in NBA history his four year
contract with the Lakers 152 million
dollars but with all the reaction and
there has been a lot of it it's clear
that members of the league don't agree
with him I believe he wasn't educated on
the situation at hand Lakers star LeBron
James criticized the decision by Houston
Rockets GM daryl morey to support Hong
Kong protesters support that jilted the
profitable relationship between the NBA
and China so many people could have been
harmed not only financially but
physically emotionally spiritually yes
we do have freedom of speech but there
can be a lot of negative the NBA's
damage control began last week after
Maury tweeted an image saying fight for
freedom stand with Hong Kong the tweet
was posted days before the Lakers were
scheduled to play preseason games in
China the Chinese government was furious
stripping down NBA signs and canceling
the players media appearances in team
events his voice really goes a long way
there's no question he's the most
influential player voice in the league
Washington Post reporter Ben Gulliver
covers James and the Lakers why doesn't
he stand up for Daryl mores tweet which
most people wouldn't consider to be that
controversial here in the United States
basically saying fight for freedom and
stand with the protesters we didn't hear
any of those words from LeBron James
tried to clarify his comments last night
on Twitter writing I do not believe
there was any consideration for the
consequences and ramifications of the
tweet
not discussing the substance the MBA has
already been working to fix the
relationship with a major market across
the Pacific they wanted to stand up for
his freedom of expression but they also
wanted to make it clear that they had
respect for China's history and its
government and they you know essentially
they didn't want to anger a very
important business partner and the MBA
has had a relationship with China for
decades it's worth billions of dollars
to the NBA and to put this into context
more people in China watch the NBA
Finals than here in the United States
Tony as it all Jonathan thank you very
broad is also gonna be in Space Jam to a
film which is expected to do really big
box office he's taking I mean he's
getting eviscerated on social media for
this he's being called brainwash putting
business interests at a democratic
values somebody tweeted social justice
apparently begins in America but ends
that communist China's doorstep Wow you
just seem to see if he has more to say
yeah after this he doesn't want to
comment on the substance we'll see maybe
he will weigh in Jonathan thank you very
much